what do you think of the fact that
keeping up with the kardashians they
just announced is going to end
i just heard that i think just like with
the simple life i
just was over it i wanted to just focus
on my business
they have huge business empires i'm sure
that's
what they want to spend their time doing
that and being with their families
you know i haven't spoken to them about
it so i don't know what the reason was
but i'm assuming they just have so many
things going on and
you know after 20 seasons you know
i think they're just ready to live their
life and not have to be on camera every
second
could it be that they land somewhere
else they go to a digital service or a
streaming service what do you think
oh i didn't think about that but you
know
such a boss that who knows
will probably be hearing something
because she's a genius
you put kim on to the game when you look
at them now
what do you think of as you think back
to one time she was just your assistant
i'm really good
are you good really good i'm not good so
we're gonna win tonight hopefully
it makes me feel incredibly proud
i've known her since we're little girls
and
the empires that her her sisters her
mother built
is just amazing and i love them all so
much
and i just it's exciting to see your
friends do well
keeping up with the kardashians is over
after 20 seasons that is 14 years
living with this show you have been the
executive producer give us the scoop
behind the scenes was it a unanimous
decision did his family members still
want to participate but others did not
what's the scoop ryan i think in talking
to
the family this was a very very hard
decision for them to make and
and i know even you know before and
after the announcement came out
they were emotional we were trading
texts and emails after the announcement
uh and you look back at 14 years and 20
seasons of a camera
in your life and think about that at
some point you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it but when you
think about
this show and kris jenner and i were
speaking of this today when you think
about how it started
and where it went and how it evolved no
one
would have ever imagined that and so i
think it was an incredible ride and
honestly
that family and that franchise i believe
has changed entertainment forever
and to see what they built out of a
little cable show the businesses they've
all built
is pretty remarkable you built something
pretty remarkable too are you going to
build some specials and maybe
some spin-offs from now that keeping up
is going to be coming to a close
i don't know the answer to that we have
not crossed that bridge yet but i
i do know that the family is so grateful
for having the opportunity at e and
having people
um right along with them through
relationships and pregnancies and
separations and breakups i mean it's
it's pretty cool
to see that they have been so vulnerable
and open and people have ridden along